right now puberty is telling you
to step on the gas if your vagina was a
car what would it be
a ferrari stays covered up and
completely untouched in the garage
mine would definitely be a transformer
you think you know her
boom autobots pop out i feel like if
you're following the metaphor that means
you have crabs what
we finally tried reverse cowgirl and
amazing right
it wasn't that great for me but i feel
like it looked cool
i was a horse [ __ ] and i haven't even
had my first kiss oh
[ __ ] look at hunter who plays hockey in
a cardigan he's like an athletic
librarian
you know sunny's throwing a party really
love a good high school party
with the liquors and the touching all
the other stuff
drugs it's a big night for you inviting
your crush
partying and drinking i feel so
stimulated is this what white privilege
feels like
okay good choices
oh [ __ ] lupe i
had sex what you banged your crush at
your own party
you are my hero oh god
i was peeing and a condom
fell out what i'm kind of full of goo
let's get the point b pill is there an
alternative you mean a
plan b sorry but i declined to offer you
the plan b
bill have a nice day back let's go to
planned parenthood in rapid city hey do
you realize this is our first official
road trip
where are we on here what do these red
lines mean
this really it needs a pension zone
i hate to tell you but planned
parenthood is probably closed for the
night my 24-hour window is closing
so the condom just fell out
i've been there
[Music]
it's like a really small chance it might
be pcp
[Music]
you